just two days away from what could be
the biggest movie of the entire summer
The Lion King and last night Beyonce
dropped her new music video for the film
it is epic but what did it take to
convince Queen B to return to the big
screen after nearly a decade a bit in
shock and I'm a part of this film
because I grew up loving the Lion King
so it helped that B is clearly a fan but
it also took director Jon Favreau about
three years to get the busy superstar
cast as Nala and the role needed a Sasha
Fierce update he put Nala right
alongside Simba in the big fight and I
thought that was really interesting and
very real because who you know with the
fighters these three also likely help
seal the deal being a mother my family
is my biggest priority it's not many
films that the parents can go and feel
the way I feel about liking and share
that past that legacy onto their kid
Beyonce released her spirit music video
last night in an ABC News special
she just reshot scenes last week at this
Arizona waterfall when you're the queen
you can close down part of the Grand
Canyon just 24 hours notice who helped
her do that co-star James Earl Jones's
brother handles Arizona's filming
permits but in total the waterfall scene
is 10 and a half seconds
seven-year-old Blue Ivy's in the video
and sings on mom's Lion King inspired
album out Friday the significance was
not lost on Beyonce's Destiny's Child
bandmates because of her two little
girls what she's packing on for her
family I think is really awesome
[Music]